he's left for helgesen a probably Matt
Matt massacred that name says who has a
higher IQ a really gifted mathematician
or a really gifted painter very
difficult to say but I would say that
gifted method because if they're both
gifted they both have high IQs you can
be certain of that it's very difficult
to do anything that's truly gifted say
above the average above the norm without
being without having a very high IQ and
in a creative realm I mean you hear
about these idiot savants who have like
one area of extreme expertise but
generally in those cases it's not so
much that they have one area of extreme
expertise it's that they have one area
of above-average expertise that really
contrasts with the rest of their
impairments but they rarely if ever make
it into the you know the very short list
of true geniuses mathematicians are kind
of an odd Bunch though because you they
peek really really early like if you're
gonna be a mathematician and truly
gifted then you're going to show signs
of that when you're like seventeen to
twenty something like that whereas
painters can can be creative through in
their entire lifespan I would say
probably on average I would guess this
is a guess that if you took a hundred
really gifted mathematicians and a
hundred really gifted painters that the
mathematicians would have far higher
nonverbal IQs but the painters might
have higher verbal IQs so that also
complicates things see with IQ also you
know there's there's this factor called
the G factor which is the central
element of intelligence and it seems to
be associated with such things as head
size and brain size relative to body and
neural conduction speed and simple
reaction time like really basic
physiological markers and it's a pretty
tight single factor say as opposed to
the personality dementia may where
there's five quite clear factors but I
think it was Earl hunts research
indicated that as people get smarter and
smarter
variability between the subsets of their
intelligence starts to increase so it's
sort of like there's a lot of ways to be
really smart but there's only one way to
be not very smart so that's another
little tidbit of information with
regards to IQ